[Music]
[Music]
episode of hot fox and i'm mike tyson
i'm evan britain and the guest today is
the one the only exhibit yeah how you
doing I'm good how are you I'm doing
well how are you man man um you know
about five years ago we had been you
know trying to do other things as far as
being in the cannabis industry it was my
first time like really trying to figure
it out I had like a edible that I
created first was some partners of mine
and then you know we went on to you know
creating a brand napalm out of some
flour and then I just kind of tested the
waters and then the vape thing started
really happening and so two other
business partners in mind we set out of
my studio and um pretty much kind of
came up with the idea of let's create
this bait that we feel like we can you
know really dominate the market you can
have your fate with you doing with you
that I didn't bring it with no yeah
because I you know that I was uh I was
really more interested man it's honor to
sit here with you man I want to tell you
one of my heroes
you know I don't know how many times I
didn't use you as some of my records oh
yeah name dropped you off
no it's a testament to your power man
and your presence brother and I'm really
blessed to be here man we talked about
it many times the the integration or the
close tightly knit relationship of Mike
and hip-hop
yeah yeah a little bit more about that I
mean I think it was you know it was a
combination of how powerful he came into
the scene and how viciously he disposed
of his opponents and it's like as a as a
hip-hop artist as somebody that wants to
have that same kind of presence it was
like the comparison was so it was like
the go-to thing you don't know saying it
so you know people still understand the
importance of sports and hip-hop and how
it goes hand-in-hand is there's a
running joke that sports you know
basketball players want to be rappers
and rappers want to be basketball
players all right right and so it's so I
think with Mike it was just so so
powerful like I said and so legendary
what his career created and you know
it's like it's never be duplicated you
know so that that's why hip-hop was so
intrigued with that you know yeah yeah
you know I never um never looked at my
life from that perspective I didn't know
hip-hop was a way of life that we were
living and normally all the people when
hip-hop when I first heard hip-hop I was
a I was locked up in a reformatory and
we heard it on the radio and a bathrobe
rapper's delight'
all right and so um we were absolutely
crazy to before then we were always
bring our turntables out in the park or
somewhere the center and we would play
our own music music that everybody hated
normally everybody playing the stylist
was if we were screaming but it's not we
were just making our statement not be
known to ourself we were making a
statement yeah without even knowing
so hip-hop kind of came the earliest of
it was off at the end of disco that era
like wait 70s yeah it was the beginning
of hip-hop yeah I was born in 74 right
and so my first encounter with hip-hop
was
like rapping Duke da da da and then do
you know don't don't don't don't
those were like my first encounters were
hip-hop and then as I got introduced to
it my older brother he brought he was
the first one to bring home the Run DMC
racing hell cassette it was a green
cassette and then I started listening to
that and then he had a Kangol that I you
know he would I was never allowed to you
to wear his Kengo or use his way for us
but every time he left that's exactly
what I did I put it out and take off my
shirt and I try to emulate you know LL
you don't know saying like those were
like the real grassroots approach that I
learned that pop remember when Biz
Markie and Fresh Prince
I'm Will Smith was on the same crew yeah
yeah yeah I went to see them perform on
their part was 1986 85 was in Hartford
Connecticut I went to see him perform
was everybody was there crazy bro oh
yeah I love to hear how Mike you know
you you were so influenced by hip hop in
the the relationship was mutual in that
way well listen we were all that was
dumb if you were listening to hip hop in
1982 85 86 back to aid back then if you
listen to the back then you're pretty
much um and outside in society you know
I mean different person who listened to
music
no one knew what these people were
saying and now it's the biggest John
were it's taken over pop music it's it
become it's become the new pop music
DJ's have definitely developed and
evolved over time credible yeah there's
a fan there now the frontman you know
yes whatever the back means exactly and
that's all work side that's just all
from the um my belief all this stuff is
comes from the
universe you know me nobody's gonna be
second everybody's gonna be first but
because it's gonna be in their time yeah
it's gonna have their chance to be first
anyways I'm not going to be number two
or in the backseat forever yeah yeah
absolutely man
can i fire one of these I should have
offered I think I think let's look at it
right hip hop is what the 20th century
really well this I think it's one of the
biggest inventions in the 20th century
yeah absolutely it's designed by people
who didn't have much and who didn't have
the access to the big equipment or the
big marketing or the big promotion it
was kids that wanted a voice and created
something with what they had and with
that it just turned into a whole beast
and it's been you know saving families
telling our stories being able to to get
things out into the open and issues that
we have that nobody else was paying
attention to you know before the
internet it was music and music told
those stories and it and it told about
the environment of what these people
were going through and so we we've
inherited something that wasn't there
before and that's really dope that's
that's kind of what Mike was saying um
you know it definitely changed people's
lives you know hip-hop give people more
than any other music I've heard so far
besides some drave type of music right
it gives people um it gives them soul
yeah you know next time we yeah so
people who never really possess the so
people who appeared that they didn't
possess is so awesome become soulful
yeah you know yeah whatever the
situation is so Goldy its peak he become
social energy could be how it turns out
so yeah I totally know what you mean I
think what's really interesting about
the evolution of hip-hop right now is
that for a long time we didn't
understand it it was a music business
and we were just
excited about making music right but now
there's more interest in the business
side of things that we have more people
that are started to invest in themselves
and I think owning the business is
something new for us and so going
forward I'm pretty sure it's going to be
a step up from you know what we've been
doing in their 90s and early 2000s late
2000s his ownership is is more prominent
in hip-hop so you got people that are
starting these labels making more
favorable deals being able to do more
for their communities with these things
in these entrepreneurial ideas that they
have is so um I'm interested to see what
the next 10 years is gonna look like
with that my state with that attitude
when it comes to hip hop in and its
artists you know you are a super
influential piece in the transition of
hip hop as counterculture into the
mainstream you were helping people and
making like [ __ ] dope ass cars out of
these like shitty some dude as a sheet
and you turned it into just like the
ultimate I don't know that's just how I
wear you fun
well I was born in Detroit the 74 like I
said and then my mom passed away when I
was like 9 and so my dad got remarried
they wanted to live in Albuquerque New
Mexico so I spent about seven years in
Albuquerque and then after that I left
Albuquerque at like 17 they came to
California and I've been here ever since
Wow yeah yeah only mom passing you at
night yeah no it was uh I mean you know
a changing moment absolutely different
yeah yeah I mean at nine years old
you're like really different you can't
we can't really wrap your head around
death at nine you don't know how final
it is you know um and once once she
passed it was like difficult for me too
get past that cuz my dad got married
like right away you know and so I didn't
have time to grieve or have time to
really you know get through the process
of grieving and being able to go forward
and so I was kind of stuck in this
pattern for a long time and I was very
angry
I was very violent I was doing a lot of
you know [ __ ] that kind of made me um
like hard to approach you know and so I
carried that anger with me for a long
time until I found hip-hop and I was
able to kick and scream and yell and
curse and get those feelings out you
don't have sin and be able to translate
all that anger and pain into the music
and so it's like I had pieces of my
mother that I know resonate through my
through my creativity and because she
was a teacher she was an English teacher
and she like brought home our lesson
plans and like used them on us and
before she used the monitor students and
so that's kind of where you know the
pieces that I take from her I realized
what they are and I think her for my
gifts you know so I was able to come to
terms with it to get to a place where I
could actually be at peace but later on
in life but when it's it's it's weird to
lose a parent like that it's not
supposed to happen that way so the
looser that early was really a tough
place for me to be but but my father was
there and I think it was harder on my
sister then you know as it was for me
but she didn't have a role model at
least my father was there I was able to
look at him find his mannerisms and try
to you know try to try to relate and and
and and listen to his guidance but you
know it's difficult for him for my
sister to see that in the same way you
know she had her dad but she needed that
womanly you know encouragement and
development and you don't said so I
think it affected us two different ways
but it was regardless of the fact losing
a parent that early is something very
difficult to bounce back from yeah I'm
gonna say something but you did it yeah
absolutely
did it and I don't even know st. Angela
we don't know we did it you know
sometimes we think we we overcame
something because
he succeeded in something you know and I
don't know if we ever come Nestor I lost
my mother 16 I've never overcome that
never some time thinking about the
relationship we had after while we
didn't have a healthy relationship mmm
because of our situation and think about
that I think about my mother a lot more
than I thought I would be yeah yeah I
mean it's it's I mean there's people in
your life and then there's family you
know I have a big family and and on my
mother's side of my father's side you
know my father just died recently and so
now the you know I've had conversations
with people to say you're not really an
adult until until both your parents are
not here with you because now you got a
sterile your own - you got a yeah you
got it you got it you're an adult now
you don't have anybody to fall back on
and ask for advice you know exactly what
to do you know what's right and wrong
it's up to you to execute you know so
that's where I'm at with it man I got
two boys I got you know a family of my
own now and I get it you know and I'm
just trying to be the best man I can be
for them you know that's what we can do
you know sometimes I do some
self-evaluation and myself and I wonder
who's the first me who was the first man
who was the first me on the first Mike
Tyson that's the first guy that's the
first male of my jeans who was that guy
how far does that go back how far as my
jeans exist
yeah yeah yeah
we've been talking about reincarnation a
lot yeah and you know we've talked about
this and I think that you know it's
[ __ ] crazy as this might sound I've
definitely lived many lives here before
yeah my wife is that old tell Matt
himself Hugh says I've been a conqueror
I'm in the slaves yeah yeah I've been
I've been um you know I won that some
time concepto my wife sister baby if you
really believe that do you believe my
wife is just such a
paranoia about flies roaches stuff
flying in our house until she freaks out
right sorry baby you think about that
one of these slides one of these roaches
that you're trying to kill her this is
freaking you out there's nowhere near
you but it's in the house we're doing is
freaking you out and it I do think
they're so like okay so I'm not a really
religious person but I do know I am in
touch with my spirit you know and I know
that that is a real thing and and I feel
like the lessons that we don't learn in
a lifetime
maybe you be sit back here you can't go
to the next level you can't go to the
next step until you've learned that
lesson absolutely that important thing
that makes you whole yeah and I don't
think any of us can go forward in this
life for the next without being a
complete you know yeah representation of
yourself you know and that has to be
that has to be from from inside and you
know what's right about you you know
what's wrong about you it's about you
know entering and rising tonight
occasion you know and making that change
yeah if that's what you want to do some
people live in dark and they stay in the
dark yeah and they don't care about
coming out the dark and that's right
yeah I'm flying through nice lines and
it's up to you to make that decision of
who those people are and either you can
disconnect yourself from them or you
know you can keep him at arm's arm's
length but still you got to know what's
right and what's wrong for you I chose
not to stay in a place of negativity or
depression or or or just trying to be
around people that I feel deserve that
kind of respect when I'm not even
respecting myself
so it's like you have to make those
decisions for you I'm not really care
about who it affects but the people that
care for you and love you you know
yeah do this getting deep yeah well my
question is like if we come back how do
we know we visit a decision you make
from me
I'm asking the questions you come maybe
you come back no my wife was looking at
this guy right watching it's what yeah
and that would be an ultimate universal
lesson yeah that you would have to be
exercising
sit your ass down that's no I dude I
totally were that resonates with me
big-time about you know every whatever
it is if we are coming back here
lifetime after lifetime it's about
figuring out be coming home you know I
think why did we become the way we
become like I said my one time listen
right he's surprised to [ __ ] read
books about tyrants and stuff Achilles
Alexander the Great discrete you know I
mean Charlemagne all these guys clovers
Belisarius all these great warriors
right oh man I ain't seen him in tights
Oh what's that power what the hell and I
and I used to focus mean I wanted to
fight great to see this especially time
to conquer I'm the best in the world I'm
just another man that's planning our
brave that can be all the crazy stuff
and all that listen right and all that
stuff
led me to really evil people will
despise real parents of their countries
all over the world
yeah I would go to Russia she's got to
pick me up I know who the
cooking had me getting a car come meet
these guys right knee thumb just for my
energy I had I would meet these guys and
I realized no I'm not these people they
don't care about nobody but they cared
about me thinking I was dumb them
somebody like them they say wow I'm
somebody that probably should be around
I was like then I realize I wasn't like
those people and I didn't want to be
like though hmm that's what I ever
wanted my whole life that people fear me
and power and all that stuff and then I
thought that real people that won that
do I want to be like whoa
mmm yeah I could imagine that's a that's
a crazy realization dude yeah but that's
like I said man you got it you gotta be
able to know who you are yeah I think if
you don't get to know who this is right
here I think that's a wasted life ya
know what's in here you don't get all
I've got it what it bring you I think
your life is wasted yeah couldn't agree
more
couldn't agree more well back to your
earliest question Mike about the
earliest version of yourself yeah I feel
like when I was a little kid I always
had this blueprint of who I knew I was
even though you know five years ago I'm
I was not the same guy I am now there
was still at least the slightest
vibration of something consistent from a
long time ago you know and that's what's
really gotten me on the path that I'm on
now you know where it is all about me
you know it's all about what's going on
in here you know that's a really special
journey to be on I feel blessed to be in
that and I really like that and I know
what else what I did the toad way I did
it and I think it's not good I've done
to acid I've scored but every time I
told to do anything I always worried
about my family if something might go
but once I did the toilet not worried
about nothing
my own entity was just me and my own
existence nobody else existed hmm you
know I must have did that [ __ ] wrong I
did mushrooms what I did mushrooms twice
it every time I think I did it wrong
[ __ ] he thought took too much or what's
not good with your experience oh [ __ ]
dude really man it was it was it was a
terrible experience man first time I did
mushrooms it was I was I was a kid and
this this guy gave me a whole bunch and
I didn't know you know it was you
weren't supposed to eat the whole thing
so I took I took like a handful and then
I drank some orange juice cuz he said it
intensifies the the the what whop
and then they were see gave me a vitamin
C pills so I was laying out of control
it was very bad yeah so long story short
we drive about an hour to this party
this house party and so um you know it
hit me at the party and so I heard her
go to the bathroom and then on the floor
I saw the flow go and settle back down I
was like oh [ __ ] man and so my friend he
was you know my friend breasted peas
Lamar he was with me and I know if I was
freaking out he'd never need never
didn't even smoke weed so I know he was
tripping right so by the time I got out
there he had you know been sitting on
the couch and waiting on me and I could
tell he's freaked out and some somebody
said some to him and it was like slow
motion he stood up and I knew he was
boxer puncher and he sucked his well he
sucked his person and so it just so
happened it was the owner of the house
and a whole football team was there as
well at the party
so we're tripping on these [ __ ]
shrews and if we try to fight our way
out this party we get into this car and
so they throw him bottles and stuff in
the car so keep in mind it's my first
time doing much
so we're driving back on the way back to
the crib and if you've never done Truths
before it takes you on this emotional
roller coaster if you're not prepared
for it or know to expect and so
wieszczyk we was like oh man you suck
there brother
so we crying and laughing and crying it
like we just like really really beaks of
it yeah it's intense dude
yeah and so I don't even know thank God
we're in the middle of the desert so we
couldn't really hit anything so we just
driving down this highway we get to the
house
and and you know at this time it's
full-blown and I'm calling them I was
like how you stop this [ __ ]
man shut up drink some milk he's like
nah man so then I'm like okay I just got
he's just heated said man relax it's
gonna go away just just relax your
understanding and just chill so I was
like okay I got to be safe I got to be
safe
let me make the house safe so I had a
shotgun okay I had a shotgun and I I was
like I gotta take the bullet side of
this the shells out of this right now
could to make the house sing so I take
to save the up I'm dumping the shells
out you know and so I thought I had
dumped all of them out because I died in
my hand I counted six but in reality it
was only five right and so did I drop
the chambers back right hand put my hand
on the trigger
drop the chamber boom oh my god [ __ ]
that [ __ ] went off right next right next
to my my right foot did it had it was a
carpet was carpet in the room so it was
a lot of smoke a lot of dust it was like
conch it was a big concrete chip right
next but nothing nothing hit me you
don't say nothing hit me no shrapnel no
rocks no nothing it was just boom my ear
oh [ __ ] and so I drop I dropped a update
I you know I I there was a house full of
people right so I go out there like I'm
okay look it's a chair swinging just
like her [ __ ] was out they was
did nobody come around that corner to
see if I was all right
right and so so I'm just like you know
that [ __ ] shrooms man I'm doing I got a
prostitute with me I'm with the over
this house we have this house and it's
some white people that seem pretty
harmless so I go over there we do
mushrooms and I'm yes and at this time
we shake people were taking shifts
coming in the house you know first of
this nice little white crew came in
there cool dony black guys really
harmless and I'm like and then later on
the morning boom there's some brothers
in there I didn't know this white guy
knew any but they got to different kind
of energy right so eventually I go hey
guys you want anything
and then my [ __ ] radar yet [ __ ]
freaked out of my mushroom whoa they
want some [ __ ] trouble
my ego he didn't say no champions okay
champ I love you sure he didn't say am i
eager ones in there like bow down say
some [ __ ] babe I know you make me feel
confident make me feel comfortable to my
[ __ ] eagle with a boom right
one of them was looking at the
prostitute I was with right and she I
think she's smoking she said baby I
think one of them gave me a [ __ ] down
or something oh yeah a Mickey or
something and once they did the gospel a
[ __ ] off club yeah I thought the
Gulf nice to live
dude on the man Brad boom right through
the guard took our other one locked
himself in the bathroom I'm trying to
get him to come out here coming through
the door baby baby grab me out I'm
something crazy man of the mushrooms had
me freaking you gotta be out in nature
for this and then we went in the car to
try the car we couldn't ride it couldn't
see I get in over the light on the
street yeah so pretty much yeah that
solidifies it yeah yeah I'm cool man I'm
cool your head difference yeah from the
era where it was like 40s and and blunts
and in marijuana like that was the co2
you don't I'm saying and now it's like
hardly and then when you had money you
got champagne and hard liquor and [ __ ]
like that but now it's a whole different
thing I don't understand in the lien I
don't understand the pills I don't
understand you don't sound like that's
that's coming that's coming in the young
generation know how that got attractive
I mean we did we had our share of [ __ ]
and then there was people yeah it's
people - did coke
you don't say back in the day but it
wasn't like yeah the lien and it wills
there you know weird man yeah you know I
worry about little Wayne they say he's
using that stuff yeah I mean I was
worried for a while yeah I don't know
man I just didn't see the appeal you
know yeah
and the pill [ __ ] either I mean I want
to be awake I want to see [ __ ] I don't
want to be knocked out you know yeah
yeah I want to be able to see it the
brain flowin you know when you think
about it you know I can't believe this
[ __ ] I used to do human species is the
only species that takes you that they
know is gonna kill them well no there's
no animal does that or nothing we don't
only species that takes you that we know
is gonna kill us
hmm that's interesting animals know to
go leave a certain amount of time the
first thing they do is multiply and then
they die
you know me gratefully yeah yeah
some people treat life like they you
know like they don't respect it or you
know it's who are you yeah why are we
here yeah what are we gonna do about it
mmm what's the real purpose I know we
all have lives
yeah my black why is hurting people like
the skin to me
you know I mean why some people 80 why
people have different cultures to me if
my purpose here is for my ego to leave
something behind for people to remind me
I remind anybody else who I was hmm what
was the real grand scheme of things you
know Who am I and what is my purpose
here like have you heard of the hermetic
alchemy what alchemists sound like
alchemist yeah okay so alchemist is
supposed to be able to make turns turn
let's go wait yes thank you main and all
those guys yeah it was started by this
guy Hermes trice megistus back in Egypt
he came from Greece and he was supposed
to be the reincarnation of the Egyptian
god of wisdom Thoth the Ibis the god of
wisdom and magic and his whole thing is
about how the universe is just a mind
it's all in mind it's all consciousness
like the universe and everything he has
these seven principles and you know one
of the principles is that everything is
just energy because this whole thing
started with a vibration sound and then
energy developed or came from that and
we are all this is just like a weird
perception we have that things are solid
but on a microscopic level everything is
just particles and molecules and energy
and we were all really connected and
I've come to this idea or you know it's
come to me about how our lives are
really nothing more than these physical
manifestations of the greater
consciousness being exercised in this
physical form in this physical realm the
universe just wants to see what it's
like to be Mike Tyson I don't know man
it's super deep it is you know it's
silly I'm really having a pot
conversation but your ass no but I agree
I agree man I you know I like I said I'm
not a religious person but I know the
spirit is real and so I guess the only
thing I can do instead of trying to cuz
it'll it'll it'll drive you to something
and I and I don't want it to be rushed
into believing what's what everybody
else is you know I think I'm the leap
system it's inconceivable right Anna man
you brought your brain is making this
[ __ ] up right Yeah right
think think you can't believe your mind
can do this yeah so I just try to be a
good person man and after if when I pass
a good person a good person is it's just
you know trying to try to be cordial and
respectful to as many people as possible
until proven otherwise that your
experience is a good person no no not
necessarily I'm just not talking about
me because I Know Who I am
you know it takes a certain person to to
want to murder somebody and then it
takes a different person to want to
murder somebody behind their back
you don't I'm saying without them
knowing and
you know then there's a different person
that doesn't want a murder at all you
know I know in my spirit I don't want to
murder you don't know saying but I mean
I'm gonna try to live my life towards
that way as much as possible and so
funny that you said that because driving
here talking like that and for my
experience that having this conversation
and talking about the evolution of
people and thinking of people that were
all capable of will come from savages
who all have that in this yeah yeah
absolutely are there but the laws I all
just made is put it in captivity you
know we're afraid of laws and stuff and
on but that's who we are
exactly yeah I mean we all have the
potential for violence we all have the
potential for doing harm but it's a
choice you know it's a choice you have
to make for yourself and whether you do
it you know some have to work harder
than others you know but for me you know
I I know that I want to be creative that
I want to leave something of a legacy
that people will be able to relate to
and expand on and that's what I'd like
to do that's that's for me trying to be
a good person that what happens after I
pass
who knows if I get there and you know
there's a god or energy source or a
black hole or I'm reincarnated as a rock
you know regardless I want to be
prepared for that next step you know and
so I think having your karma clear
having your spirit you know clear um and
we all make mistakes we all do things
that you know we regret over time but
trying to realize what those are what
those were and navigate past them and
you know in the future you know how do
you forgive yourself oh you have to what
steps do you go by doing that what do
you say to yourself under forgiveness I
mean it's like I think making amends to
people that if you can helps and then
being able to know that you've
acknowledged that I think acknowledging
your wrongdoing is half the battle you
know knowing that you did it saying
you're sorry to know apologizing to
someone that you may have done
- or you may have just done it to
yourself you know you have to realize
that okay cool
I did it I know I can't get that time
back some things you can never repair
but be okay with that and realize what
it is accepted and move forward you know
and like I said in the future try to
avoid making those same mistakes again
that's the only way you can do it but
it's so necessary to be able to get past
that and respecting that and forgiveness
being able to forgive yourself is being
able to acknowledge it and not do it
again I can dig it
yeah I don't know man but being able to
forgive is powerful and forgiving
yourself you have two men again carrying
things you know forward past where they
need to go is something that we all used
to I mean we all do it yeah it's just
something that you mean it takes a lot
of energy to hold a grudge yes I
personally have done Gus and I don't
have the bandwidth to do that anymore
you know I have things that there's more
people that appreciate me than don't
yeah and so instead of focusing on the
people that don't you can never stop
some people are never gonna like you and
that's all right I don't have to focus
on you but there's more people that like
me than don't
so I'll focus on them and keep my energy
there because we spent so much time
talking about haters I got haters and
haters dissing yeah [ __ ] that yeah
these people don't are probably fans in
the first place
yeah and just don't have no other way to
communicate right you know believe it or
not hate is the lowest form of love you
don't saying yeah you're existing in
their mind yeah yeah existing in the
existence yeah you know I was throwing
one I hate you if they even think of it
why would they want to give you that in
yeah going out of my way to go shout at
people I don't like yeah you know and
obviously you are bringing some kind of
energy my way because you don't know how
to say it no other way right you know
but but I move forward to it and that
now I'll only focus on the people that
appreciate me to love me I'm not worried
about converting anybody or making them
like me because you can't do it it's
impossible yeah love who love you yeah
sometimes you can't take that hate and
anger and pain away forever so what you
have to do is figure out how to channel
it like I said earlier when I was when I
when I knew what I was going a certain
route I was like when I found hip-hop I
was able to channel that and yeah it
didn't go near I was still angry but I
got I found an outlet where it didn't
harm anyone and I was able to like kick
and scream and fighting and say crazy
[ __ ] that I want to say instead of
saying it to people like I said in this
forum where everybody was kind of
speaking their feelings and speaking
their truth and I wasn't gonna be
reprimanded or locked up for it I was
actually gonna create a little negative
into a positive and have a career that
was gonna sustain and you know we're
still here so it's like those feelings
may not go away you may have a
legitimate reason to be [ __ ] mad yeah
but you got to find that outlet that
that that is going to be somewhere where
you can get it out but at the same time
you're not gonna be hurting bringing
harm to yourself or others yeah and
that's that's the challenge and that's
really difficult to do for sure like
what do you think no I think this is
interesting release speaking like a dick
that shirt both you guys have dope-ass
song
well I being shout out to roots of fight
oh yeah they're cool I got the champ on
the shirt hell yeah hell yeah yeah come
on man Mike what do you see when you see
that guy right hey that guy's too good a
guy he's know who that guy is so when
you look at this guy this guy is just
some a [ __ ] insecure kid afraid of
everything and one somebody to be afraid
of him cuz he's afraid of everything he
thinks everything comes from fear cuz
he's been bullied all this life and [ __ ]
picked on his [ __ ] Wow but she was on
top of the world and we didn't see that
that's so crazy we didn't see that we
might what we saw you fight man it was
like this is like what it is is like
he's going in there with purpose and
[ __ ] when we [ __ ] love him we
didn't see the
here we didn't see all that we just saw
[ __ ] beast mode like knock that
[ __ ] out that's what I was for
the next thing I did there [ __ ]
you're next wow man well it's the most
amazing thing ever in perspective is
everything yeah you know yeah yeah
perception you know it's about who you
are what made you become a rapper has
been something that's a Hey
no it's listen listen yes in boxing as
well him I mean right we see a
[ __ ] we don't know nothing about
him and our whole life that that's one
going to be don't know nothing about no
no the intersections of what he did who
he is what he's about
but what that image I want that that's
what I want to be and that's just I know
[Music]
that's what I wanna be [ __ ] who I am now
like I feel [ __ ] like I want to be out
leave well man I I when I was when I was
coming up man like I said I looked at
all the rappers that were like really
like out there like Eric beer mark him
Big Daddy Kane NWA into Ice Cube era I I
was a fan I studied these these artists
you know ll poor righteous teachers you
mean you name I studied all aspect of
music and enough hip-hop especially and
so what I actually got to work with dr.
Dre and work with Snoop and worked with
it with em and and all these guys and
you know III came up reading the back of
NWA records and now I'm in the room
working with dr. Dre and Snoop I mean it
was incredible and so we always you know
you know push ourselves as always I mean
it's but I know we saw that but what was
it about them that what is it that you
wanted that they had the something that
they had that you want it well I mean it
for me well when I first came up the the
whole money thing was not real prevalent
in hip-hop it wasn't
like the thing it was more conscious it
was more society related and the
gangster stuff came in and and then it
was kind of like even then it was kind
of like the lowriders and it was never
glorp money was never glorified so my
attraction to them was the creativity of
being able to hear a story then close
your eyes and just hear the music and
you could damn near see everything that
they're talking about the creativity of
being able to put words together the way
they did and my comprehension was really
high again like my mother was a was an
English teacher so I was very intrigued
by the smarter the rapper then the more
intrigued that was because he was able
to put words together that we're not
what's not easy to do so that was kind
of like my draw to it and then when I
found out that you know a lot of these
people you know had writers and a lot of
you know a lot of you know said it's
like okay well I've trained myself and
home myself for in order to be that you
know so - so I don't have to fake it or
get people like that so it just
empowered me once I figured I once once
I got the The Wizard from behind the
curtain I was like oh I see what it is
now so okay cool well I just I'm I'm
more better prepared to take this
journey so I was attracted to the
creativity of it and then once I got
behind I got to see all the you know
stylists and dress you know and all the
lights and the cameras and the bells and
the whistles it's like oh so I just
really came in and started working with
them with raw talent then I learned how
to do song structure I learned how to do
you know like hooks pre choruses verses
and get more creative with the writing
and they they really like sharpened me
into an artist you know I came in raw
and then I was around those guys and I
learned how to be an artist so that's
what drew me to it initially and then
all the other stuff happened afterwards
Muhammed Lee was champion I am a taste
and I'm so awesome during this time like
when during this fight thing people will
faint
they were fainted baby they be out
through the whole fighting mr. whole
fight pain that's excitement crazy it
was almost like godly stuff in this guy
you can't you have you ever met him
no I do oh it's me he's just the
humblest man and all that he's done and
said stuff he's just it was just special
yeah
what was the first time you met him
right I met him I was in reform school
around 76 how old were your family 7 or
10 11 oh wow
Wow you met him at young Oh 12 year he
was come he came to visit us before you
even sorted boxer and I was good about
boxing in my life never knew anything
about boxing Wow yeah man we watch the
movie the greatest and he came in he's
talked to us for why we asked and I said
I listen I want to be like him Kemp and
never got in trouble again I turned
after their institution I met somebody
another institution needs to be a
professional boxer he taught me how to
bark and I got to good so he said my
take you to coffee they take you to the
next level and this is why I'm here now
wow that's so cool dude well I never
knew that yeah how many people know that
I don't think I've told my book my story
I think a bigger that's that's why I
remember but then everyone thought about
being a fight that's why I was like the
moment all those people come in there so
it's big tough car like a little girl
terminus and I saw all the crying I
really knew we was what did he do to get
these people to do this didn't he that's
amazing powerful there yeah
when you can reach out and create that
lane for yourself you know and now you
know you consider it one of the greats
like you know yeah I mean regardless of
how it is I mean the world loved you man
you know and I'm honored to be sitting
across from you man I gotta tell you man
you you one of my heroes you know I
gotta keep saying that Thanks
yeah I know and yeah absolutely
absolutely but you know as somebody
coming up you know that's how we looked
at it I mean but that was what we loved
that was it I mean this rough right
there
it's rough out there and you represent
it being you know you represented us
like you came in there with no fluff no
shiny [ __ ] black trunks town [ __ ]
black boots whoop-ass let's go home
let's go home
that was it man and we loved you for
that man and we still love you for that
because of what you represented man and
it's the same principle in the basis of
hip-hop man you coming from nothing you
make it something and that's all it is
that's where it starts that's where it
stops for me you know we all have ups
and downs nobody I'm not looking at that
you know understand cuz the first man
with no sink it skidding cast the first
stone and you know they ain't gonna be
dang he'll be no stones thrown you know
so that's how I see it Mike that's
that's the truth you know and like I
said but I'm very proud of what you've
done I see you know I've started reviews
on a one-man show ality undisputed and
now you got Tyson ranch you know saying
he's breaking into and representing this
cannabis space well because there's not
many people that look like us in this
space and and and we it we get from we
open up to absolutely man whatever you
need for me Mike I'm there for you this
time
absolutely man I saw I saw the
renderings I know you got a big big big
big project coming and whatever you need
for me brother well from brass knuckles
will be that you were grass knuckles
I see brass knuckles all the time on the
thing yeah absolutely tell me about that
I always ask me about breath the guys
with the vapes yeah yeah yeah I got two
other partners we created brass about
five years ago
yeah are we in business with them do we
know that
yeah that that's I got two other
business partners we started about five
years ago and we created this how's it
doing after they don't work I'm hearing
about it
it's great man the brand awareness is
really well you know we're gonna roll
with the punches with you know the
regulations as they roll through and
change every week every day every month
and you know but we created a brand that
we're really proud of it's in California
and it's in Nevada and now we have plans
to you know expand go across the country
and I mean it's been a great experience
for me because I didn't say exhibits
brassknuckles for a reason we wanted the
brand to be the star you know and so
once we put it out and we it we became a
lifestyle brand and something that can
be very recognizable not only just in
the cannabis space but just as a brand
period and so as we expand across the
country it's gonna be exciting because
this is you know but before the big boys
come in and and the big you know form
the money and you know tobacco money
comes in there's a real opportunity for
the people who really are into the
culture and from the culture to come in
and actually build these things that you
know show it how can be done the right
way and attract the right people who
want to come in and be part of this this
wonderful community man but it's the
tobacco people a people I mean they're
gonna come in regardless because once
it's federally recognized it's gonna be
you know they're already all hands on
that yeah they're there sneaking in yeah
and they're coming in through these
corporate you know like catalyzed you
know stock Bisons and and stock you know
exchanges and you know but it's until
it's federally recognized it won't be
time to play hardball yeah but right now
there's a time to go out and really
create they want the the infrastructure
to be set first and then they're gonna
come in and that's what they're allowing
us to do yes you know the saying
the infrastructure then come in and and
buy out the biggest people worse yeah
well I mean you know it doesn't mean
that they can't come in and do it the
right way - right right now right but I
mean they're gonna they gonna throw
their weight around yeah of course they
are but but again I mean it's like that
meant that matters not if you determine
you have a dope vision it's gonna work
you know you know we started with with
six thousand carts
you know Wow and then created brass
knuckles as it is today so you know
shout out my partner's Mike and Dave you
know yeah um we've really created got
some brass knuckles yeah man it was it's
been it's been a rollercoaster but it's
been fun - man yeah yeah that's awesome
music yeah you know a lots changed since
I came out and I know that you know I
don't want to make trap music I know
that's very popular um but I I feel like
I just need to do what I do really well
so you know I got a I got a I got a
buncha guys around me that you know
range from the classic artists all the
way down to the new guys coming up so I
could hear it and I know different
energy is is in the youth now you know
and so I have to respect it you know do
you think is talent they have do you
think they have time in it in their way
in their way yes you know what I'm
saying because because in my way you got
to think about it and it has I think
this is gonna sound [ __ ] up but it has
to do with the education and the and
being able to retain information now
kids have this pseudo technology that
they don't have to retain anything like
we did we I had encyclopedias and I will
have two right hand right all my essays
and school reports and all that stuff by
hand um we had the the most the most we
had was a typewriter right but now these
kids have this pseudo intelligence they
at any at any second you could ask them
a question
and they can google it and they could
know the difference that the distance
between Earth and and Saturn to the
exact thing or or they could take
pictures of their dicks no or their food
or their cat
and so they have this extra brain that
they have to carry around with them and
so it makes it so that you okay so so
I'm smarter than you because I have this
technology right what what it really
does it kind of like it kind of
handicaps you it is you you're now in a
place where you relying on this thing
and I do the test i how do you know if
the phone's lying to you now yeah it's
new you don't even know if it's true
information but I took all the phones
out the studio and I said okay guys
write down four phone numbers that you
know by my let's write a call your mom
without the diamond we didn't have them
phone books and phone exactly yeah and
so that was my point okay so because you
have this technology doesn't make you
smarter so I think we came from being
able to okay whether you want to learn
it or not as you do in your reports
you're gonna look over words and you got
your comprehension and your word what
you learn right now we don't want now
it's like okay so I don't know a kid
that doesn't necessarily understand what
that means or have the patience to
figure out what that means they don't
want to hear that [ __ ] you're talking
[ __ ] NASA to me bro I don't want to
hear about the medical pharmacal in the
end I like [ __ ] I wanna feel the beat
magic library that's what they want
[ __ ] bed in the corner to live baby
so I talk to these guys in the studio
and it's like you know I just want the
vibe I want to feel the energy and
that's and that's it but that cool to be
able to speak to that energy is a talent
sure because I will come in a different
way you don't have said but they know
how to
speak to that generation and so yes it
is a talent because when I came in the
way I we we got we share music that was
for our generation we could understand
the language now it's different now it's
a different thing there's people that
sit in this room and love hip-hop music
and then they'd be like okay what do you
say well I don't care about the words I
just like the beating yeah now it's
about the beat right yeah what do you
say yeah they just want to hear to beat
and so now it's so so everything goes in
cycles you know there's right but now
people will eventually get tired of that
and want to hear something with some
Eric yeah right no what's the most
important thing in the world in the
universe has ever been is information
when four as time goes on we give more
information now yeah too much at times
yeah and through it and eventually we
come to the stage where we stop lying
and you tell the truth yeah that'd be
nice
even the the process of having to dig
through books or textbooks to learn
something or to write a report to
compared to just googling it right and
it's just pop so hard part of learning
is that process right going through it
repetition
you know being able to you know after
you know know what where in the alphabet
the words you need to look up literally
be able to you know phonetically get
down to where you need to and then find
the definition write it out it's there's
something about writing and and
retention of information yeah and and
that's it man is yeah I bet you're on
that process is gone it's gone and so
now it's kind of like you see you don't
even know have to have to know how to
spell correctly yeah you know it's so
now is kind of like we're relying on
this pseudo technology this this zoom
pseudo intelligence I'm sorry I'm lying
to it yeah yeah that's probably you know
that that's kind of you know you know
over time being able to be swerved and
curved either to the right or to the
left you know depends on weight it
depends on who who's in your
your website right you know in your
Google so it's a different thing yeah
yeah I just I still read books I still
you know right yeah you know because
that's what I know I mean just because
it's there I mean is coolest convenient
you know I could write notes I could
make phone calls but you know I'm not
gonna put my put my bet on there you
don't know saying yeah I don't want to
become that dependent where I just
stopped using this yeah and depend on
this yeah
[ __ ] man you think we're good well how'd
you get the name exhibit how'd you come
to that actually it came from well when
I first started writing I was 13 years
old and it was like ice-t Ice Cube you
know all these guys you had ice or MC in
front of their names
MC Hammer MC serch you know MC ran you
know I'm saying young MC it was like MC
was the go-to just like it was like that
times little you know like everybody
knows little less a little less know
right I was like why do you wanna be
little so at that's how yeah at that
time it was MC this right I'll MC that
or ice something you know I'm sayin so I
was like I want to go to the the
opposite end of the spectrum and so I
was at a battle one day I still hadn't
figured it out and that was it we used
to battle at lunchtime so I was battling
in this this guy named Tony I never
forget Tony and David David used to
beatbox and Tony Miss this country dude
they used to try to rap like but he was
seeing other people [ __ ] like he was
seeing the wraps off the radio and he
had his tiny bow
like like and so I it's so much and so
one day I wrote my own rap and I said
that rapping it was like all right I
said his name and he's like yo man you
said exhibit a you know and then um and
so that's where it started one of the
things in was exhibit a because my real
name is Alvin right so I was like oh
yeah I'm gonna just use that exhibit a
and then I spilled it regularly with the
e first exhibit a and then I dropped the
a and then put an X and a Z when he
bollocks came to play
and so it just became exhibit and then
that's what I started riding under so it
were a development over over over time
you know great name thanks man yeah it's
dope as hell bro you're on the right
team at the right time to back in the
day when I was cool that day just really
many but I think I seen it before I know
we're never that close to them before
that's crazy bro well thanks for coming
man thanks for having me thank you
all right Mike another great app brother
yeah take this out dude all right man
hey everybody thanks for listening to
another episode of hot box and subscribe
to our YouTube channel hot box and with
Mike Tyson and on iTunes
Hey
when people know we're yeah how to get
in touch with you anything absolutely
thousand people are cool at exhibit X Z
I bi t on all social media platforms
you're awesome man yeah well thank you
again thank you guys man man yep awesome
everybody we're out of here yeah
[Music]